on est supermarché les prix explosent
autour de 17% et en particulier ceux des
aliments premier prix autour de 30 % le
cercle vicieux de l'inflation bah son
plein la pauvreté explose et
l'alimentation devient bien évidemment
le budget d'aliment le budget
d'ajustement des ménages c'est un recul
terrible la proposition loi de ma
collègue Francesca parce que ni propose
justement une réponse d'urgence avec une
prime alimentation de 50 euros par mois
et par personne malheureusement vos
troupes l'ont réduite à une aide sèche
de 2 euros 2 euros par an et par
personne monsieur le ministre ma
question est donc pourquoi votre
gouvernement fait le choix de mettre en
danger sanitaire et alimentaire la
population française vous seriez un peu
plus crédible dans votre indignation si
vous aviez voté les mesures que nous
avons adoptées pour le pouvoir d'achat
des ménages les plus modestes
vous sauriez un peu plus crédible vous
et toute la nupette et toute la France
insoumise si vous aviez voté la
revalorisation des aPL la revalorisation
des minima sociaux la revalorisation des
bourses étudiantes dont vient de parler
Sylvie retaillod le repas 1 euro pour
les boursiers vous seriez un peu plus
crédible dans votre indignation sur les
travailleurs si vous aviez voté
l'indemnité carburant pour les
travailleurs pour ceux qui travaillent
pour ceux qui sont les plus modestes
vous sauriez un peu plus crédible dans
votre indignation sur l'inflation si
vous aviez voté le bouclier qui protège
tous les ménages français contre
l'explosion des prix du gaz et
l'explosion des prix de l'électricité le
coût des énergies et des carburants est
un niveau rarement atteint et
aujourd'hui ce sont les produits
courants qui ont vu leur prix augmenter
de manière insupportable le lait plus
10%, le beurre + 20 %, les pâtes plus
32%, les œufs plus 10% et dans le même
temps les vols à l'étalage explose mes
chers collègues quand on a de l'argent
on fait des choix mais quand on en a
plus on fait des sacrifices dans le même
temps vous refusez la taxation du super
profit qui permettrait d'aller chercher
vos recettes ailleurs que dans la poche
des Français et vous refusez notre
proposition du TVA à 0% sur 100 produits
de première nécessité et je vois que le
rassemblement national à la même
indignation de façade que celle de la
nupesse ça ne me surprend pas
la récupération
des marges sur les grandes entreprises
énergétiques ça s'appelle la
contribution sur la rente infra
marginale elle rapporte plusieurs
milliards d'euros elle permet de
financer notre bouclier sur le gaz elle
permet de financer notre bouquet sur
l'électricité elle permet d'éviter des
augmentations de 180 à 200 euros des
factures par mois et Madame Le Pen vous
n'avez pas soutenu la contribution sur
la vente infra marginale vous ne
proposez aucune solution pour protéger
nos compatriotes contre la flambée des
prix quant au prix de l'alimentaire j'ai
demandé au distributeur de mettre en
place un trimestre anti-inflation qui
est impliqué actuellement et dont nous
vérifierons la mise en oeuvre j'ai
envoyé aujourd'hui la lettre qui demande
au distributeur et aux industriels de
rouvrir son délai les négociations
commerciales pour que les prix de gros
qui commencent à baisser commencent à se
répercuter sur les prix à la
consommation